We pulled in for the final episode
the darksaber the way the darksaber
came about was I was a Mandalorian they
proved this look this lightsaber was
stolen from your Jedi Temple by my
ancestors during the fall of the Old
Republic since then many Jedi have died
upon its blade prepare yourself to join
them just working on Jon so what how do
you make a thing that has no light but
just has but what we're digging is
actually that much like the old
lightsabers that there's actually a
practical practical element it has weird
anomalies that like alright look yeah
that makes it look like those reflective
dowels that they use and actually one
was a spinning reflective Dallas's oh
that's something that we have to kind of
you know experience which is when we do
take things that it like came from like
the Clone Wars we have to think that in
that show they're stylized and that that
was like an animated style of something
from live-action and it's not about
doing any of those things one-to-one but
it's about saying that's baby
yeah that's through the land what George
have done it copy that locked in for
three five
in episode 105 we get to go back to
Tatooine and we go inside the moss
eisely cantina
it should look very faithful to the
original we did about a little bit less
than half of the build we were able to
build a recreation of evey 99 which is
now the bartender Droid Mark Hamill came
in and voiced the droid who had appeared
in Return of the Jedi unfortunately and
then I'm driving R5-D4 through the
scene
hey droid I'm hunter, I'm looking for some work
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going to be
my new Star Wars Mandalorian video about
the darksaber they talk about during
that clip and the secret Mark Hamill
cameo scene that's right Luke Skywalker
secret cameo during the Mandalorian
season 1 and I didn't see anybody
talking about it during the actual
season so it sounds like nobody spotted
it when it actually happened so we'll
break it all down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos and we'll do a new Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your
theories and predictions about the
Mandalorian season to on the video so
just starting with the darksaber stuff
first just because that's relevant to
what's going on during the Mandalorian
season - Jon Favreau and Dave Filoni
explain how they did the darksaber why
they did the darksaber because they
could have picked any common type of
lightsaber to use during the
Mandalorian series but there's a lot of
special reasons and connections between
the darksaber the Mandalorians the
Mandalorian character did Jaron himself
in some of the upcoming characters
during the Mandalorian season - that we
found out about I love the way that they
talk about how they tried to recreate
the look of the original lightsabers
that they used on the set of the
original trilogy when they were filming
that with the reflective tape Dave
Filoni was also very clear about how
they couldn't do it exactly the way it
looked during the Clone Wars just
because that's animated it's made to be
very stylized in its look and feel and
they had to make it feel like an actual
lightsaber during the Mandalorian series
because it's live action but as jon
favreau says during that the importance
of the darksaber is that it actually
started out created for the Clone Wars
for his special character Pre Vizsla he
played another character that
Mandalorian infantryman during the
Mandalorian series who was part of the
vizla clan so this
another link to his original Clone Wars
character but the reason why they
created the darksaber in the first
place is because he was working with
Dave Filoni and Skywalker Ranch while he
was working on the first Iron Man film
and Dave Looney was working on the early
seasons of the Clone Wars
he asked Jon Favreau to participate in
voice a character just for fun so in
order to make his character Pre Vizsla
feel like more of a badass going up
against the Jedi because it's the Clone
Wars they decided to give him a special
weapon to fight the Jedi so that's where
the darksaber originally came from
George Lucas helped create it because he
was very involved in the development of
the Clone Wars series then later it
became a much bigger thing so timeline
of the actual darksaber in the
Mandalorian series between the Clone
Wars and rebels because we can actually
track who had it where did Moff Gideon
get it we actually know a lot of these
details the darksaber was created
thousands of years ago by a member of
pre-business clan who was the first
Mandalorian to ever become a Jedi when
he died the darksaber which is
basically just another type of
lightsaber was kept in the Jedi archives
during the fall of the Old Republic a
group of Mandalorians from pre-business
clan stole it back from the Jedi
archives because it was still during the
period of the Mandalorian Jedi wars
where the Mandalorians really hated the
Jedi they kept it for eons and used it
as a symbol of power to rally their
culture around uniting the Mandalorian
clans it became a symbol of leadership
that was then passed down through the
generations and eventually landed in
previz TLAs Hands who at this time was
the leader of the Death Watch
Mandalorians who are the same
Mandalorians that rescued dihn Joran as
a child during the Clone Wars we saw
that flashback during the Mandalorian
episode 8 so at this time when this was
happening Pre Vizsla was actually part
of this clan wielding the darksaber in
real life it's a picture a real-life
version of that character running around
wielding the darksaber then later
during the Clone Wars when Darth Maul
took over Mandalore he took the darksaber from Pre Vizsla
then when he barely escaped at the end
of the Clone Wars he went back to
Dathomir left the darksaber there until
Star Wars rebels which takes place right
before the original trilogy during that
series it was taken back by Ezra Bridger
and Sabine Wren so Sabine Wren winds up
using the darksaber during rebels for a
while then at the end of that series
gives the darksaber
too lady Bo Katan to reunite the
Mandalorian clans right before the
events of Star Wars a new hope then we
don't know what happens to the darksaber
there's this missing time period
during the original trilogy after Return
of the Jedi about five years we seem off
gideon showing up wielding the darksaber
not really knowing how he got it
but we do know about his backstory in
how he's tied to the Mandalorians as
they explained during the Mandalorians
season one Moff gideon was actually a
member of the Imperial Security Bureau
that was stationed at the planet
Mandalore during the great purge which
was happening at some point during the
original trilogy we just found out that
Katee Sackhoff is going to be playing a
live-action version of Lady Bo Katan and
the Mandalorian season 2 she's listed
for at least one episode on the IMDB but
the actual episode that she shows up in
is kind of an unknown they just list her
for episode 1 but that's not accurate
it'll probably be some other episode so
if she's still alive but Moff Gideon has
the darksaber that means that at some
point during the Great Purge he either
defeated her or captured her and stole
it from her at some point in that's why
he has the darksaber now in present-day
What has Bo Katan been doing this
whole time she's not the armorer I know
there's a lot of secret theories about
the identity of the armorer early
prediction though is that Bo Katan has
just been hiding out like the other
Mandalorian clans in secret like Din
Djarin's clan was hiding out underneath
in the sewer system there's also rumors
about them doing a full-blown ahsoka
live action series so I'm assuming if we
don't see Sabine or Ezra show up in the
Mandalorian series we'll see them show
up on that ahsoka series Giancarlo
Esposito has talked a lot about his darksaber lightsaber fight scenes that he
has during the Mandalorian season 2 it
sounds like he's in a lot more episodes
and a lot more scenes during season two
to have that many big lightsaber fights
but I think when he says he has a lot of
darksaber fight scenes he just uses the
darksaber fighting a lot of other
people just carving through them like a
hot knife through butter
but as for the Mark Hamill secret cameo
in episode 6 so obviously it's the
Tatooine Boba Fett episode full of all
kinds of fanservice because they go back
to Tatooine and there's all kinds of
references to Return of the Jedi and a
new hope they go back to the exact same
Mos Eisley cantina now being run by
droids who used to be denied entry and
there's an Eevee 99 droid from Jabba's
palace
serving his bartender but he's voiced by
Luke Skywalker himself Mark Hamill
don't feel bad if you didn't spot this
when the actual episode happened because
as you listen to his voice again now
they processed it a lot so it'd be
really hard to tell that's actually Mark
Hamill doing that voice I don't remember
anybody commenting on this during my
episode 6 video there were a lot of very
obvious Easter eggs particularly the
boba fett one at the end of the episode
I've already done a couple of season 2
videos about Boba Fett so I'll link one
of them at the end of this as for Mark
Hamill coming back I know because we
have all these Disney live-action series
people have wondered if we'd ever see a
young version of Luke like what's going to
happen with him during the obi-wan
kenobi series because during the events
of that Luke will be a young boy so
they'll probably have to cast at least a
young person to be that character if
they're going to show him on-screen so if
they do a young version of Luke at some
point it'll probably be a younger actor
that they'll recast everybody keeps
talking about Sebastian Stan because he
even did a funny audition scene as Luke
Skywalker in the ways of the force we
call in Jedi father
they just Sebastian Stan having a little
bit of fun but this is a lot of fan art
of Sebastian Stan as Luke Skywalker does
he not look like he could be Mark
Hamill's son in real life what's going to
happen later this year because they
cancelled Star Wars Celebration because
of the virus that's where they would
have brought the Mandalorian season 2
trailer the full official trailer
they'll probably release that online
when they start releasing the new Marvel
Disney Plus series when they start
ramping up to promote that that'll be
some time towards the end of the summer
early fall the Mandalorian season 2 is
already confirmed to premiere some time
early to mid-october
I'll keep doing more Mandalorian and
Star Wars videos as we get more
information about season 2 but leave all
your requests in the comments below and
I'll let me giveaway winner the next
time I post a Star Wars video everyone
click here for all my Mandalorian season
2 Boba Fett videos and click here for my
Mandalorian season 2 ahsoka
teaser thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe I'll see you guys
tonight!